hello everyone welcome to another
YouTube hang out super excited to be
here with you today today I have a
special repeat guests Monica from Aweber
Monica welcome back I thanks Devon it's
great to be here again monica is a
content marketing specialist with Aweber
Aweber is the email marketing software
company I've used for the past ten plus
years to help run my business and today
we're going to be talking about how to
create a remarkable first impression so
as an entrepreneur when you're trying to
talk to customers is it with the media
or partners or employees how do you make
that first great impression and we want
to take your questions to that's the
most fun of all of this so what the side
there's an ability to write in the chat
and a bunch you guys are already writing
in that's awesome if you have a question
for us sleeping in there and we will get
to it live but before hopping to the
questions Monica do you want to share
just a little bit about what you do at a
weber and then your thoughts on how to
create a remarkable first impression
sure so I'm a content marketing
specialist and that means that I write a
lot of content for a weber so we write
content that talks about you know the
benefits of email marketing and also to
educate our customers on how to use the
product and kind of how to use email
marketing as part of their overall
marketing and this is worth strategy as
well so that involves blog content and
email series website copy just any type
of writing i am partaking in that so
it's really great um and the question so
for creating a remarkable first
impression you know writing content I do
get to dabble in part of that experience
and trying to help create that
experience so I would say that you know
the most of one of the most important
things to think about when you're
talking about that first impression is
that it's not going to be necessarily
any one particular place the way that
consumers and customers interact with
businesses nowadays you know it's not a
linear type of journey it can be at
people can come in at any different
point in time and that means they might
be coming into onto your homepage or
they might be seen getting to know you
through an email
series they might be getting to know you
at a conference so they're meeting you
in person and interacting with you so
you know you always want to make sure
that all of those pieces of the puzzle
you know that they're telling a
consistent message and that they're
really for training your brand in the
way that you want to be portrayed so you
want to make sure that you're getting
your purpose across at any point in that
journey um for example you know if you
write a blog post about email marketing
that that could be the first experience
that somebody has with your brand so
that could be that first introduction so
you want to make sure that the content
you're creating is is educational and
providing value and you want to make
sure that there are other ways that
people can learn more about what you
have to offer too so you know just bring
your a-game to everything that you do
and it's kind of a kind of a big kind of
answer but you know I can't emphasize
that enough oh yeah one of the companies
I'm involved in is a salsa dancing
company and were the largest i think in
north america teaching people how to
dance salsa in our first class that we
don't teach salsa we teach merengue and
for those of you who may know the
difference merengues a lot easier
merengue is fun moringa you don't have
to worry about your feet you're just
using your hands and kind of marching on
the spot and so people get it quickly
and they have a good time really quickly
and then in future class we get into
salsa and I take that same approach to
making a first impression to make an
introduction to creating content right
the headline matters and you want to
make it that merengue experience so that
it's a little hint it's fun that has
some wow factor but then to get to know
you and get to work with you may be a
much deeper and longer conversation so
if you're looking at what can I do to
get on somebody's radar to stand out to
have something that when they first look
at you or see you or hear what comes out
of your mouth or they see your email or
they see your website or they visit your
blog or they listen to your YouTube
channel that they're hooked immediately
with something that's curious and
interesting and that dries them down too
deep a conversation with you so we've
got a lot to talk about but I also want
to make sure we get to tell you once
it's on there Monica I just say that's a
great metaphor you know just making sure
that you're you know providing some sort
of entertainment
actor too and just really exciting and
you know you want to peek people's
interest and their curiosity so great
the great metaphor and it's it's like
it's what we actually do right like it
helps our business because salsa is hard
to learn as you give them something easy
to understand first ah cool well let's
get to the questions so guys you have a
question for us leave it on the side box
that chat and we'll get to it first up
relaxing sleep station how to determine
if you I'm ready to make that first
impression count if you're starting from
a place of having no relationship your
audience what do you think so i will
definitely say you know as far as
whether or not it's time you know any
time is the right time you have to just
really get started with creating that
first impression and just getting
yourself out there you know to stick to
the main pole just stick to trying to
help others and keeping them in mind as
far as you know what value you can bring
to them um you know and just get started
and as you kind of it as you kind of
begin to interact with new individuals
over time you know you'll be able to
improve that first impression experience
as well oh I also you know but French
and this want to give a quick shout out
to there's a free guide that anywhere
put together we'll talk a little bit
more in the session too but if you check
out the description you can see the free
guide and get some ideas and maybe some
questions from there as you go through
the session um for me how to know one to
make a first impression you know there
is there is definitely you can go into
soon and you cannot be ready and you can
you know make an embarrassment of
yourself I think what you have to do is
be able to provide value and I look at I
look at working with gary vaynerchuk as
an example he had an endorsement of my
book that we used on it when I first met
him I didn't really have an audience and
I didn't know him I just wrote to him
but I i created a line of entrepreneur
trading cards and I wanted him to be on
the back of one of the trading cards and
I wrote to him putting this cool project
together you want to be involved in it
who's your favorite famous entrepreneur
and he put Vince McMahon from the WWE
and so like what's the value that I
could provide to him it was
that I had a massive youtube channel i
wasn't even on youtube at that point it
was that I'm doing this cool thing he
might want to get involved in for other
people when I tried to reach out again
without much of an audience I would go
out and make Thank You videos so for
some YouTube influencers when I was
building up my channel I would contact
all of their fans and put together 50
responses that they said hey hey Gary I
love your videos thank you so much like
people who he might recognize his loyal
fans and put them all together and they
get 50 people to say yes i'll make a
video means you have to contact like 500
people because most people won't do it
but then I send this video to him with
this insane message from all these
people it shows the work so you may not
be able to approach somebody on a
business partnership level you know they
me not you mean I have enough value yet
they're from a business context but you
may be able to provide other kinds of
value that can stand out and that's
that's your main gold I think if you go
in trying to pitch value that doesn't
exist or where they don't see it then
it's hard to it's not going to be
remarkable right they're not going to
enjoy what you have to say you're
probably going to get you know deleted
in that email or have the door closed
but if you're giving them something that
does make them say wow that's the trick
you got to find out what is it that if
I'm trying to get on this person's radar
what would make them say wow and I'd
like to add on to that to you know I'm I
know last month and then you spoke with
one of my co-workers Mike Smith about
creating a remarkable remarkable brand
story and I think you know taking the
time to really identify that story and
who you are and the type of value that
you provides others that can be a really
great stepping stone as well we
reference the the free pdf that is in
the link you want to just quickly talk
about what's in there because it will
help people create that remarkable story
for themselves yeah sure so there's
actually a couple of documents in there
so there's the worksheets you I'm help
you create your own remarkable story so
that really taps into the value that
your business provides to your
and then we also speaking to creating a
remarkable first impression we have a
couple of worksheets in there that help
you set show you how to create an
awesome lead magnet piece and an awesome
welcome email series so the value there
is that you know a remarkable first
impression you know it could either be
you reaching out to somebody else or
somebody else coming to you so when
somebody is coming to you for example on
your website or on a landing page you
want to make sure that you're giving
something away that provides a really
awesome value gives them that really
great experience and kind of helps them
learn a little bit more about your
business and what you have to offer so I
definitely encourage you to check out
the more shades that are there you'll
see how to create a lead magnet like an
e-book or a checklist that you can offer
to exchange for your website visitors
email address and then the worksheet
also goes into you how to create a
welcome email service which provides a
lot of really great information on you
know really how to set up that welcoming
experienced and how to make how to get
your subscribers really engaged and
learning more about your business so
definitely check those out and if you
have any questions about those now be
happy to answer them to love it and and
that's all free stuff guys you don't put
your email address in there anything you
just click and download um next up is
Ken right in to say i love these videos
this is the first time i've caught one
live what's the best impression to give
to a naysayer of your ideas so how do
you deal with the haters in that first
impression so behaviors she knows some
people just aren't going to like what
you have to offer and that's just kind
of the way it's going to be sometimes
you know you can't always win over
everybody and that's okay so kind of
getting to that point where you're
comfortable with that and you know
really bringing in people who are going
to get the value out of your business
you know sometimes you just have to let
people make those decisions on their own
but at the same time you know if there's
an opportunity for you to kind of come
back with you know not necessarily
anything people are mean but if you can
just provide them with additional value
to counter counter their points that
they're making that you know they might
disagree with or you know if there's
other value that you might be able to
bring to them
and that provides a different type of
help of help then maybe there's
something there that will draw them into
you what do you think Evan I think it's
easy to get lost in a fight or in a
debate right it's easy to challenge
somebody and spend so much time thinking
about the people who don't agree with
you and I think it's just human nature
that if you get you know 99 compliments
and one insult you just your night lane
and we think about that one insult that
you got and I think to have success as
an entrepreneur you need to be you need
to be forward thinking like you gotta
move past this this is going to keep
coming out the more success you have the
more impact you have the more haters
you're going to get and if you spend
your time just worried about their
thoughts and opinions and try to
convince them then you're not building
anything of meaningful or lasting value
I don't like being in the business of
trying to convince people of things I
just it's possible it's just it's so
much work and it's so draining and if
you spent that time on something more
positive and more powerful you will to
create much more amazing things and so
if somebody is not interested in what
I'm all about or worse like hating on it
then I try to spend the time just you
know ignoring those guys I'm moving on
to something else you know we call them
the little men on our Channel and we
have like hashtag little man going to
hate and then just move on to the next
positive comment I think luckily we have
a good a good community here we don't
have a ton of haters you don't have a
ton of little men but but still I
wouldn't worry about it there's a lot of
people who want to buy what you have and
can find value in what you do that it's
going to take you 10 * long and try to
convince somebody and just going to
drain your energy just like you want to
be around people who build you up will
give you energy who lifts your spirits
who try to make you the best version of
you and not the people who just you know
continue to suck your energy and tell
you all the reasons why it's not going
to work at so it's normal don't freak
out just move past and start working on
the on the people who are aligned with
what you're all about
that's what I would say it's a great
point yeah I think just just staying
focused on the value that you provide
for your audience so you know that's
really gonna that's really going to help
you stay focused and um will help you
get over some of those negative comments
that you here too I love it somebody's
in the comments saying that there's
they're loving we sheet so we should cup
TV is watching and someone else wrote
awesome channel description ricci cup TV
so Rishi whatever you wrote in your
channel description is making a good
first impression so we should maybe
check that out and model at some point
um let's get going to the next one I
dash writing in if you have good ideas
and you know how to work hard but you
don't have good communication skills how
can you impress people it's great we've
got good ideas you work hard but you
don't know how to community of poor
communication skills how can you still
have that first good impression I think
just you know trying to get that get
your hard work out there I'm you know
just really practicing those
communication skills and really just
kind of developing them I you know I
don't want you to feel discouraged that
you know it's now's not the time because
you don't have that set in place I'm but
if you have great ideas you know and I
definitely encourage you to to check out
some different resources that are out
there to kind of help you overcome some
of those challenges that you're facing
and really just get started because
sometimes the best way to learn is just
my practice yeah I have two thoughts on
this uh one would be you don't need to
be the greatest communicator to get to
get value across just work on condensing
it down I remember as an example when I
was was sending Gary the thing about the
blog he likes emails that are all in the
subject line so like no email just the
subject line hey Gary can I use this in
my book yes that's how he communicates
uh and so just
I mean having the practice mule to get
it down so it's shorter if you're ever
doing a sales pitch you're ever doing a
you know a bio or due respects in an
elevator pitch the more you do it the
more comfortable you get at it the
faster is going to be and the challenge
with communication is getting your point
across without saying a thousand words
and it's always wait longer the first
time you do it and then it gets
condensed and convincing and skin it's
down so practice and not to be just
talked to the mirror talking to your
plant talking to your cat you know
talking to your friends and practicing
it making a youtube video even if you
don't share with anybody just make it
private or unlisted and you can look at
it yourself practice practice bastards
will help you get better the second bit
of device that may be a little little
more controversial I guess would be
maybe you don't like maybe maybe you
partner up with somebody who's good at
that you know if communication skills is
not what you're great at and you don't
want to get better at then don't worry
about improving your weaknesses and
instead go all in on your strengths so
what are you so good at like if we're
talking about creating a remarkable
first impression it doesn't have to be
from you going up and mean somebody at a
networking event and say hey I'm I'm
adesh here's what I'm all about like
some people do really well at that
that's also not me if you're great at at
hard-working you and you have really
great ideas start putting those ideas to
work and people will take notice and
they'll see wow that person has amazing
stuff like a lot of the best artists are
terrible communicators but you can look
at their work and that attracts the
attention and so you know people find my
youtube channel because of the hard work
and putting it in with three to four
videos a day and that attracts an
audience and that attracts interest and
that attracts book deals and I transfer
brand deals and I am NOT going off door
to door knocking on people's doors and
asking them for business so if it's
scary that you want to work on fantastic
go for it but if it's not don't feel
like you need to get this to be
successful because if you
keep focusing only on your weaknesses
and you'll never get better your
strengths and you just be mediocre at
everything which is not going to lead
you to being massively successful so two
bits of advice ticket whichever
direction you want that's a great point
I don't think that's controversial at
all you know we all have our strengths
and you know for me as content so I
focus on creating content once I start
doing anything else it's bad news that
break things that broke something this
morning and you know just trying to stay
focused on the things that I'm good at
you know I definitely agree with that
for sure what did you break this morning
I broke our RSS feed for a little while
they're so cool so next up is suyash how
how do i impress an investor with my
idea in only one minute I would send i
would suggest so uh ebony mentioned
earlier you know coming up with that
elevator pitch you know just trying to
write those things down so before you go
to that investor and start pitching for
one minute you know really hone in on
what that message is going to be and
really focus on the value that you know
your your business is providing um you
know you don't want to just kind of
stumble your way through that pitch this
is your once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
or it could be once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity so you want to make sure
that you're ready for it um so you know
practice and you know it erate on that
message and you know make sure that
you're a hundred percent confident
before you get out there yeah a hundred
percent I agree what I would add to it
is make sure that the language you're
using is general enough for everybody to
understand or at least for the people in
the room to understand if you're talking
to whatever target are just talking to
you want to make sure it's in a language
they get where a lot of times when
people are pitching investors as a you
know angel vest to myself and for my
venture capitalist a lot of the
one-minute pitches or executive
summaries would be so filled with jargon
and technical terms that you as a
entrepreneur understand and you think
you're making it short and concise but
it doesn't make sense
somebody who doesn't understand your
business inside out and no investor is
going to understand your business as
much as you do there they have sector
knowledge but you know you're in this
tree you should know your industry
better than anybody else and so that's a
challenge as 22 filled with jargon that
doesn't make sense in the industry
there's a term called the grandmother
test where it would be explained the
pitch to your grandmother and if she
understands it then you've done a good
job and you ready to move on and so to
Monica's point about practice practice
practice practice practice yourself but
then also practicing other people who
have no idea what your industry is all
about and see if they like it um I look
at my book that I'm coming up with when
i did it with the test audience only
half of them were entrepreneurs the
other half were not entrepreneurs
because I know the entrepreneurs are
going to love it it's my stuff you know
how much repairs are going to dig it but
I wanted to reach other people too who
are not just entrepreneurs and so happy
not first impression so that when they
opened up the book and they read the
first few pages or also wanted three so
if they just open up to any page you up
at the page 50 there's something on
there that will grab them because people
don't always just look at the first page
they flip and they I know when I go to a
bookstore I open up somewhere in the
middle and just see what's on there see
if it grabs me and so understanding your
audience and then making sure the
message is something that they can
comprehend really quickly once your
one-minute pitch down and also say to a
five in a pitch because if you get
somebody who's interested in it and they
ask you a question or they want you to
come in and do something a little more
detailed you might have the greatest one
minute pitching the world but then you
could you could fall down and struggle
and suffer so you want to make sure that
you have a five minute 10 minute [ __ ]
also kind of ready to go for those more
detailed questions yeah I think that's a
great point to you about you know be
careful with the jargon and the words
that you use and making sure that you
know the first impression that you're
providing to others is something that
they can understand and that applies to
not only if you're pitching Q and a
potential investor that applies to your
website that applies to your emails that
applies to your lead magnets which I
hope you're reading that checklist
checklist and learning more
out um you know you want to make sure
that you're speaking to people in a way
that they can understand what you're
offering and that they can kind of see
where they might fit into that story to
what you guys are doing since you do
content marketing Aweber when you guys
are going through that process of
creating a new blog post what goes to
your head in terms of creating that
title and then creating the first
paragraph because that's going to be my
first impression if that doesn't tell me
that I'm going to skip the page I'm
probably not going to scroll down so how
do you guys do it when you're looking at
creating a headline and creating that
first paragraph so that it creates an
amazing impression so what the headlines
sometimes we look at two things that
have worked in the past to you and you
know kind of seeing those patterns or it
can be really helpful and really telling
as to what resonates with a specific
audience so for us for example you know
people really like listicles so we make
so sometimes we make sure to you know
have that number in there because we
know it attracts people I'm having how
to in there you know that really shows
people what kind of content you know
that it's going to be something that
they're going to learn something from
and they're gonna be able to get
something directly from that and also
just making sure that it is really
specific about the content that they're
going to be learning in the article
itself so that seems kind of obvious but
you know with the onset of all of these
more clip BTW types of titles and making
them really obscure to capture people's
interest you know that's an easy way to
lose people actually so we want to make
sure that we are specific in you know
what the content is going to provide
people and what the value is there so
and sometimes that involves to you like
including really and jazzy and powerful
words you so one word that we've been
really liking is the word irresistible
so I think we wrote a blog post about
irresistible content for a sign up for
more ears a salute lead magnet something
along those lines I'm so you know really
paying attention to the specific words
that you're using to you kind of just
you know capture people's attention and
then it yeah and for the first paragraph
to you know in journalism it's very
common for you know the lead is such a
powerful moment because that's really
going to
I can really make or break whether or
not somebody can use to read um but
whatever you've written so you know we
try to do something that's fun we tried
it sometimes will start off with a
question and for sometimes will you know
start off with a metaphor to kind of
give people something else to work with
and just really capture them and kind of
hook them into the into the content one
of the things that I did really
successfully when I was doing my PR
campaigns was I'd always have a headline
in a sub headline and if you look at
newspapers you'll often see that with
the main headline in the second headline
and so when pitching your borders they
may not like the first one but they may
love the second one so the second thing
you put is also super important so if
you're looking at creating a blog piece
or some kind of press release or you
know an email there's a subject to get
them to open it but then what's that
what's that first line that comes in is
there value there and if you're using
tools like with Aweber I test that all
the time right like understanding and
created a remarkable first impression if
you're in the kind of business where you
can build a list then you can test it so
that you can figure out what the best
remarkable first impression is so that
the next person will get that and the
next person will get an even better
experience and you just keep improving
improvement improving so testing know
the color of your email is testing the
time you deliver a testing what's in the
subject line is it caps or you put their
first name in there do you make it
geo-located right there's a lot of
things that you can test to make sure
that I getting the impact that you want
and so you learn from every first
impression that you have and how to make
the next first impression better yeah
that's a great I you know we split tests
all the time and we try to see you know
what works and what resonates with our
audience and I think actually you know
you're just taking it a step back that's
what really drives the most engagement
and gives and provides them the best
person pression for our audiences making
sure that we're actually writing content
that resonates with people so you know I
definitely in kirkwood encourage
everybody to you know really tap into
what the needs of your audience is art
and you know trying to figure out how
you can provide content that really
speaks to them was there a recent tests
you've done that you you guys learned
just you personally found super
interesting a recent tests that we've
done one that we did that I really
enjoyed was actually with the use of a
gift in our emails and versus just a
static image and we found that people
who received the email with a gift you
know they really enjoyed it so we
included a sentiment widget and our
emails of people can actually say like
click a happy face behind to kind of
Express how the email made them feel so
you know I just really love that test
because we can look at you know the
numbers the click throughs and the open
rates but that doesn't always tell us
how the the content is making people
feel so you know I really just enjoyed
kind of seeing how what type of
compression we're making on people and
how it's resonating with them in in that
way so so that was fun interesting one
of the things that I was testing was
putting i found that numbers work really
well in the subject line so if people
saw the numbers or like three ways to
whatever that that did really well uh i
found that people resonated more with
how to avoid a negative situation in the
goal for a positive one so you know
seven ways to make more money in your
business versus seven ways to avoid
losing your business you're losing one
does better which pains me because I
like being a positive person when people
resonate more with the avoiding the pain
than going for the positive so like
testing those kind of things out like
tends to how to title versus testing the
three ways to do this title so that
every time you know that that test has
gone out but then the next the next army
is coming through right so you got
another audience to be able to promote
and market to and that's going to be
their first experience with you and so
you've learned from all the other tests
that you've done Rishi Cup TVs writing
in reaches the one with the amazing bio
that we're all going to have to go check
out the even a remarkable of oppression
so like that question if you've already
made a bad digital first impression what
are some effective ways to redeem
yourself thanks so they made a bad
digital first impression
I kind of think kind of think of it as
if you were to meet somebody just you
know face-to-face if you were to meet
somebody at a party or you know at a
comp at a networking event you made a
bad first impression the only thing
that's really going to eradicate that is
just by following up with a better
second impression and you know just
making sure that your future
interactions are on point and that
they're really displaying who you are
and you know really um provide that
value and really bring them into you
know what you have to offer so you know
just try not to focus too much on that
initial bad impression because there's
always opportunity to represent yourself
a second time and if there's not then
you know like we were saying earlier you
know don't sweat don't sweat the small
stuff you know there's not not everybody
is going to be a huge fan of yours and
you know that's going to be okay you
want to focus on those who who are
attracted to what you have to offer so
now I definitely encourage you to sit
either try again the second time or if
not then that's all right don't let it
don't let it bother you too much yeah um
I want to know what did you do is she
Rishi is usually like super positive and
and encouraging I I don't she hasn't so
I could someone who had created bad
negative first impression but I want to
know where she leave that comments what
you did that was so negative um I think
one being genuine about it and
apologizing if you did something wrong
and just owning up to it I think a lot
of people don't own up to their mistakes
enough and it's it's hard to it's hard
to hate on somebody when they're down
you know usually successful people don't
really do much of that if they see that
you're down it's it's not like ahaha you
suck you're down right that's that's
like a that's a losing mentality and
then and then provide more value you
know make it make it better find find
something that you can help them with
that can add value to their lives like
making a thank you video with all of
their audience or helping promote their
book or you know whatever like stock
them on Twitter and just follow what
they're doing follow their YouTube
channels see what you're interested in
see what they're up to and
see wow you might be able to help
because you may not have a huge audience
you may not have a lot of connections
you may not have you know a big network
to really share but you have you have
hustle you've got a brain you've got
some creativity and that's all you need
to do you got to fit just figure out one
way to really help them so that you can
add more value to what they're all about
something that they it's harder because
they have a negative impression of you
now um but you know they do know who you
are which might be better than uh then
not knowing who you are but just just
added more value like the people who add
value on my channel I know who they are
like we she's been in a lot of the
chance I know who she is right so how
did that happen like this Rishi have a
huge channel know that she have a huge
network has she you know bought a
thousand books no she hasn't done any
that but she's showed up and added value
and helped out and so you could do that
too just understanding what's important
to that person and in figuring out some
creative way and as entrepreneurs that's
what we're good at being resourceful
being creative some creative way to use
the talents that you have to provide
value to them in some way and that has
to be remarkable because you created
that first negative impression I don't
advise you you know when you're and when
you're adding focusing on adding value
you might not necessarily be resolving a
problem that they specifically have but
you never know where in the future they
might see something that you create and
they are impressed and you know they
finally have that moment where they feel
like you know you can help them and that
they have a connection with you so you
never know where they might come along
in the future and we recently launched a
campaign in called today's your day and
it's all about inspiring people to
finally take advantage of the things
that they have been thinking about doing
but for whatever for whatever reason
just haven't gotten around to doing it
so you know we've off we offer different
checklists on you know how to create a
YouTube video how to create an online
course so you know we're trying to find
ways that we can provide additional
value to people without necessarily
being you know use Aweber use email
marketing but just kind of showing them
you know we're here to help you we
know that you have these struggles and
we want to make sure that you have what
you need to get started and that you
have the encouragement there so you know
that's kind of an example of one way
that we are a weber providing additional
value to the email marketing that we
offer but you know we don't know who we
might be bringing back that didn't have
a good first impression of us in the
beginning oh you know just trying to
stay focus on helping others and helping
your audience will really help you
overcome that there was a lot of
excitement last month to run the today
is a day campaign and had lunch i think
it was about to launch like the next
week or something so where can people
find out about that is it sign up yes so
the site is alive we're still very
excited about it it's a weber com awwe
ber calm / today geo da y so if you go
there um i can always post it in the
comments in the video after 2 i'm check
it out you know maybe you'll find
something there that resonates with you
but you know just still going along that
idea of providing value i love it i love
i'll link it up in the in the
description after if those you guys who
aren't watching live um veena is writing
basically being concerned about the
other people what they will think about
your first impression and and the
negative self-talk inside your head of
what the other people are going to think
of me when i do my first speech or
article or whatever and how how to stop
the negative voices inside our head what
do you think good question we're going
we're going deeper so you know i think
back to you as well like when i first
wrote my first blog post and it was
published on the internet and you know I
was really nervous about how it's gonna
be received and what kind of feedback
people were gonna provide and you know
then I didn't hear any feedback at all
and I was like okay that's better than
anything negative but you know at the
same time it's it's all about really
practicing and just focusing on your
audience and making sure that you're
solving a problem because if you're
solving one of their problems and your
focus on that you know you're gonna
you're going to be helping somebody and
at the end of the day that's what's
worth it so you know them and the more
you do that and the more positive
feedback you start to get back um you
know that'll help you know reduce some
of those negative thoughts that you
might have but you know sometimes you
just have to take risks and try to
silence those thoughts but you know the
more you do that just stay focused on
the value of that you're providing and
just really focus they focus on helping
your audience and no that'll bring you
far yeah I think one practicing so you
get more comfortable in it you get more
confident just again if you have to go
and pitch like the other person talk
about to investors and that I'd be on a
stage and is 500 people in the room that
could be super scary and you're going to
have tons of you know negative self-talk
but the more that you practice it on
smaller stage is the easier it is so you
have more confidence going in I would
also say that not everyone is out to
laugh at you you know I remember being I
was going snowboarding and I was on the
ski hill I was on the was it called that
thing that takes you up I was feeling
the list I was on the left I'm still
pretty new at it but I was on the lift
and this is girl going down and I told
this joke before which is going down and
she's trying to do these jumps and she
can't she can't lend the jump she's
falling and she tries and they just
Falls and Falls and then I'm sitting
like aw man i hope i hope she gets that
jump i wanted to get that jump anybody
in yeah I put think the top of the hill
and she's at the bottom and she hits
that last jump and I'm like excited for
her that she got her jump and then I get
to the top of the hill I'm coming off
and I with Who I wonder if I can if I
could do that jump to I wonder if I can
do that like her and the first thought
that I had was who's around me who's
going to see if I fall and and then I
realized wait I was just I was that
person who was watching and I was
cheering her on I didn't want to see her
fall I want to see her succeed and land
that so why is my automatic assumption
that everybody was going to be laughing
at me a word that I'm gonna fall we're
really where we're on biggest critics
and so just understanding that people
you know do want to see you succeed to
not
the world is not all just laughing at
you I think those two things that's more
the mindset and to practicing so you're
more comfortable with it will help maybe
not totally eliminate that negative
self-talk but help help dampen it and
help it not prevent you from taking the
action you need to take cool i'm flying
through this so many like this somebody
shatter happening in this hard to get to
the questions to see him like scrolling
scrolling these are the questions but
next one is from Jiwon Hussain how much
does role-playing play a part so how
much is real plain pic play a part in
creating a first impression so I can't
see the comments but i'm going to assume
that means you know just practicing
beforehand um you know if you have
somebody that you can really interact
with face-to-face you know i think
that's really valuable because you can
only talk to yourself in there or talk
to your dog so much but when you can
really see how when you can really see
other people's funny language and the
expressions on their faces and you know
get that actual feedback firsthand you
know sometimes that can be extremely
helpful on a few months ago i gave a
presentation for a conference and I
practiced in front of my husband and you
know I tried to get through stumbling
and there's some of the slides I didn't
necessarily make sense but you know
really going through that exercise of
presenting um was really valuable and
really helpful for me yeah I think it's
just another level of practice we've
talked the number of times about how
important practices to getting the
confidence so that when you go out your
you are delivering to helping us
remarkable especially if you're doing it
in a situation where there's other
people like if you're doing a one-on-one
meeting what that other person might
kind of say and if you can practice
somebody who knows that person and what
they might respond to um I for example
my salsa business had my guy who was
going into an important meeting with one
of the people on our team and he was
nervous about it and said hey can you be
this person and like help me here's what
she might
a when I say this and how can I walk
through it and then we switch to say hey
here's what I would say and then you
would say well this is what she was
saying respond and so just that role
playing really helped I think it can
also kind of help though to when when
it's when you're creating content like
if you create a newsletter imagine that
like if you're selling entrepreneurs you
know I'm marketing to entrepreneurs I
imagine an entrepreneur reading the
newsletter and seen what are they going
to like what are they not going to like
what are they can resonate with when I'm
doing my book right imagine somebody
reading it and so the next time you're
creating content to you could you could
roll play with somebody who is that
customer like if you're creating content
for you know shoemakers but you're not a
shoemaker it might be hard they get
something that resonates but if you can
show it to a shoemaker and get their
feedback as they hey what do you think
then that helps make your content better
so it's just another form of practicing
to make sure that you end up with much
better results so I encourage it I'm a
fan uh Ryan is writing in how can you
make a remarkable proposal without
offending people that offending people
the more context might be helpful but
I'm you know just be mindful of the
people you're talking to if there's
something that you want to talk about or
I feel like the time when you could
potentially offend somebody is if you
try to be humorous or funny i'm trying
to think of examples um where I've seen
that happen but you know just try to
stay focused on the value that you're
providing and just keeping focused on um
what the problems are that you're gonna
that you're trying to solve you know
that'll help eliminate some of that
extra um comments that might slip out or
you know if you might offend people in
certain ways I think to just being
mindful of the way that you present your
help to others you know you don't want
to just assume that they're in a place
where they need a lot of help or that
they're struggling because you know some
people might take offense to that
um but really just focus on focus on
this whatever it is that you're
delivering and just making sure that
your message is clear around that it's
an interesting question I've been asked
this question before it's an interesting
one I think it speaks it to the to your
mindset Ryan like I don't know that I've
ever offended anybody with the proposal
that I've put together ah and you know
you can definitely offend people to make
a point you know if you are if you're
pitching a customer and you know they
you don't like how they're doing their
business and you say hey you're your
newsletter campaign really sucks it's
not getting any results at all you know
look at that that's the most boring
thing you ever seen in my life um not
that may even resonate with some people
um you know you look at Kanye West he
offends people but he also gets results
are what he's doing so should you change
I don't know that's interesting question
like okay it's easily for me to say hey
this is how I do it I don't know offend
people I think it's wrong uh I haven't
had results doing it and not that I'm
encroaching to go out and just a friend
people left right and center but also if
you are always just trying to play nice
and be safe and try to do something
that's not true to you you're not going
to be remarkable it's going to be a
super boring pitch so I don't know that
you need to worry so much about
offending people that's that strange
advice coming from me um it's such an
interesting question yeah it's a
challenging one I mean if it's your
stick then you know maybe that maybe
that works like for your brand on but
and you can always tell to you if you
find that you're not getting any
business with that approach and you know
that's going to be really telling ya I
think it's got to be something that
feels right for you and experiment with
you know like if a friend in business
offending people I think the intent
still has to be positively I guess for
me the intense still has to be positive
right like you might have to push people
through uncomfortable horns and that
might be a friend into them but the
tend to still to help them get better
right it's still a positive outcome that
you're trying to guide them through and
you know you can deliver harsh truth to
them that might come off as a friendly
but at the core is still love i think
that's that's the most important thing
for me that your it's you're not meant
you not meaning to just go out and blast
somebody but you're trying to do it to
help them and yeah like Monica said it's
got a its got to work right and every
time you do it you learn and see if it's
if it's helping you get further along
your path or if it's just constant
something you need that you're fighting
through you never get to where you want
to go there was actually I just
remembered um I forget who it was but
somebody was cleaning their email list
and he sent out an email that was you
know basically saying if you you know if
you're not a smart person get off my
list you know kind of along those lines
and he offended a lot of people and a
lot of people you know called him out on
it but then at the same time you know he
kept a lot of people and they thought he
you know had a lot of guts for kind of
taking that approach because it was so
new so you know it can be very divisive
so you know be careful um but at the
same time you know just see it if it
works for you and if it makes sense with
your brand and like Evan said if it
feels right then you know just be
careful yeah I think just one other
thing I would be making sure that if
you're offending somebody it's it's
intentional it's not unintentional right
so that's where the practice comes in
that's where the role plane comes in if
you're coming up and in criticizing
something you know that they're going to
be offended by it and it's not a
surprise to you that you said this in
that room or to that person you know it
could be something as my new des if
you're hating on dogs and that person
just lost their dog you know that's not
you're finally not going to win that
deal in that moment so knowing your
audience to make sure you're not using
words of language that would offend them
that when you do it you have you have
intent and you know what you're doing a
smile Blythe
I'll pronounce that okay uh at miss
montesa and Avan using your twitter
handle you can check you out miss Montez
making the first impression looking back
what was the best advice you have taken
yourself best advice you've taken
yourself on creating a good first
impression it's a great question I'm
going to think about that a little bit
but um you know one piece of advice that
I receive 4 i'm actually a professor
during a public speaking class was that
you know and this kind of goes along
with what Evan was saying earlier about
being your own critic you know you have
an idea in your head of how perfect you
want things to be but others don't
necessarily see that so you know if you
just stay focused and you're prepared um
you know try not to basically it all
comes down to you just trying to not let
the fear overcome your the risk that
you're taking and creating that first
impression and I think to you just you
know keeping in mind who your audiences
and just always focus on delivering that
value I can't emphasize that enough or
repeated enough I think that's the most
important thing that I've been told the
thing that comes to mind for me is seth
godin is purple cow we had that book
about creating a remarkable impression
and he has a great video I don't know if
it's on Ted or something else where
where he breaks remarkable down into
something that you would make remark
about right that's what it means it's
remarkable right so we're talking about
creating a remarkable first impression
so creating the first impression to the
point where something we want to make a
remark about it and tell their friends
would tell somebody else about it we're
using analogy of a cow if you see a cow
on the street or you're driving you know
maybe saw a cow in the street i'm in the
city if I saw counter street w pretty
remarkable but normally if you see a cow
kind of driving through farm territory
it's not that remarkable but if the cow
was purple then that would be remarkable
you want to get off and take a picture
and I'll tell your friends with this
purple cow that you saw and so I use
that thought when I was creating my
trading cards I
like baseball cards since I want to make
entrepreneur trading cards and stuff was
one of the guys who agreed to
participate um him and Guy Kawasaki were
the first two guys who I approached and
asked them who their favorite
entrepreneur was and set picked Duncan
Hines which was interesting and Guy
Kawasaki pics Steve Jobs and so just
didn't know me yeah and then the other
people that I went and connected what
they didn't know me either but trying to
do something like a trading card that
was different and special and remarkable
that they would be proud of having
helped me get on their radar and we
raised a hundred thousand dollars plus
for entrepreneurs in Africa through the
Kiva program so all of those things
combined help me get a first impression
and it's easier to kind of go back open
the door in something else so doing
something different creative unique fun
to get on somebody's radar you can have
nothing to do with the business that
you're all about like if somebody paints
my picture or somebody leaves a ton of
comment to my youtube channel or
somebody tries to help me out by
promoting my book or something like that
like I'll take notice and then I'm
curious what do you do I'll check out
your website and you know might see what
you're all about or check that your
twitter handle and see what you're
posting and so doing those little things
add value even though it may not have
anything to do with what your business
is all about just to get on somebody's
radar I've done that a lot and people
done it to me too and I found that it
works yeah I've been going along with
that to you know one thing that we have
been internalizing dirty Weber's just
the idea of creating things that bring
delight to others so it might not
necessarily have any purpose at all but
it's something that you know we want
people to see it and they're just like
Oh like that's fun like that's you know
I like that or it makes them laugh or
makes them smile you know we're kind of
adding something extra that makes us
stand out a little bit more and then
also creates a positive connection with
what they brother I love it um Beatrice
is asking does dressing up matter duclos
matter is that what most of us focus on
when they're making a first impression
so how important is clothing an
appearance
making a first impression I think it
really depends on your audience you know
there's a lot of conflicting information
about out there about that I was
actually just thinking about this
earlier today I don't know why um but
you know some people they want to come
across as really you know business
professional and suit and tie or you
know dress and heels um but it really
depends on your audience so for example
you know if you look at Mark Zuckerberg
you know he made the hoodie and jeans
really cool and he is CEO of a massive
company and um you know it really just
depends on your environment the type of
impression you're trying to create so
you know different types of clothing and
different styles are really going to
help communicate that impression that
you're presenting and its really
communicating your brand and your
culture and what you stand for so you
know if you have an accounting firm they
might be a little more professional and
you know if you show up in jeans and a
t-shirt that might send some mixed
signals and it might not necessarily
create a good impression to your
audience um because they have different
expectations I'm not to say that that
doesn't mean that you shouldn't just go
out there and try something different
because I feel like right now you know
just the way businesses are right now in
the way consumers are you know things
are changing and things are moving and
you know trying something new can work
um but you know I definitely encourage
you look to see what your competitors
are doing to and kind of see how others
are dressing the part or not dressing
the part um and get a feel for you know
how casual and what kind of image you
want to present when you're seeing
people in person when I when I first
started my business every time I met
with somebody with being a suit seems
seems far off and what I'm doing now I
would always be in a suit and I just
felt like that's how people take it
seriously and they would give me more
respect if I was in the suit I think
truly it was just a reflection of my
lack of confidence and the suit made me
feel more confident and then over the
years I got less and less suit I you
know would be business casual and then
and then this like I'm gonna t-shirt or
hoodie
much every day and when I go to events I
I'll wear this and they say black tie
event this is what I wear with black
pants and my five toe shoes like this is
me uh-huh you know I shave sometimes
sometimes I don't hopefully it's still
presentable I think I think one I've got
more confident myself than value I
provide I think to to Monica's point
there is branding and people now you
know recognize that and I'm not just
like every other guy in a suit it's it's
different it's more remarkable than like
wearing this to a black tie event is
more remarkable than trying to have the
fanciest tuxedo because everybody's in
the tuxedo we're on five toe shoes to a
black tie event but that gets questions
that stands out um does it lose me
business maybe you know maybe if people
only want to deal with you know people
in suits I might lose that client I
might lose respect to that person at the
same time though i don't know that i
really want to be in business with that
person who can't handle me being in my
Brandon hoodie and five toe shoes you
know I do i do these events with with
Stephen Kelly was a CEO of sage who's
always in a suit and is you know see of
a multibillion-dollar company and 13,000
employees and this is what I show up in
and he's always cool with it um so yeah
I mean to Monica's point I think it's
important understand your audience and
know what they're after I think it's at
the same time point to understand who
you are and have confidence in what you
wear you know you open up my hood in my
my closet and it's all black it's like
45 hoodies t-shirts see notes but yeah I
made a video on this because I wanted
this was this was a fun discussion
between me and my wife I did a vlog of
when we moved into my new place and I
said I need to be inspired by my closet
I want my closet to be inspiring i would
feel like batman going into my closet
where most people just a composite is
this a closet like who cares just closed
no i want you know like
is with intent right what's on the wall
my closet needs to make me feel like
Batman I'm putting on my suit and going
to you know have an impact today and so
that makes me feel good which i think is
more important than anything else I
think I think wearing the thing that
makes you feel most like you it's going
to allow you to shine and you be
remarkable so I think dressing to be
somebody else makes you mailed in and
makes it if you're uncomfortable wearing
the thing that you're wearing like
you've all been there if you're like you
weren't a shirt that's too tight you
know you're just constantly worried
about how you look and adjusting the
shirt instead of actually being you and
letting that come out and shine so my
advice would be the weird the thing that
you feel most powerful most comfortable
in whether that's a suit where that's a
hoodie with its of you know bathing suit
whatever it is where the thing that
makes you come alive what do you think
Monica why did you wear that white shirt
today so I it's funny like maybe this is
why I was thinking about what where did
I am i wore white sure because i know
why tis ok on screens i'ma for stripe
shirt and I no strikes can be bad
sometimes so I just went safe and plain
I love it I mean and some cultures if
you're at a company there is there might
be an office code right like you might
have to Gus up I know Nina works at an
accounting she works in accounting at a
company and she wants to dress up my
wife Nina she wants to dress up in like
business outfit but nobody in her office
does do that she feels overdressed and
you know it's like I've always dreamed
of being the place where i'm dressing up
every single day going to work well you
could dress up when you're on you don't
need them to dress up go where are you
what you want to wear yeah just do you
just do you exactly so don't worry so
much about I think like your your goal
is to create a remarkable first
impression it's going to come much more
from how you carry yourself and even
even how you see the words and then
saying specific words right and I think
about my youtube channel to start I
would
trying to memorize a script and like I
need this to the exact right words it's
got to be exactly what i wrote down on
paper and it would come off as super
force and awkward and like thinking or
like looking up to my top left try to
remember what it was I supposed to say
and so it wasn't a remarkable video
people didn't resonate with it as much
as they do now and so I have usually a
general understanding of what I'm going
to talk about but I never say the thing
that I practice saying is like it's
close but I don't worry so much about it
so if you worry too much about the exact
wording that you're going to use or the
exact clothing that you're going to wear
if you feel uncomfortable doing it then
you're not going to create that great
first impression so the the mindset and
how you carry yourself is going to be
the most important thing cool well I
know we're getting close to the time I
wanted to just give one last quick shout
out to the the PDF download that we have
up a word with calm / entrepreneurs the
one that we had from last month with
Mike about making a story remarkable is
up there still that you can download and
then today we just put live the one
about how to create a remarkable first
impression and Monica if you want to
just like quickly recap again what's in
there for people that they're kind of
last chance to go check it out yeah tour
so if somebody's go to your website you
know creating a lead magnet and welcome
campaign you know it's a really great
opportunity to kind of show them what
you're about and kind of show them the
value that you can provide to them so in
a checklist you'll get some tips on how
to create a lead magnet how to you know
I make something that's actually
valuable and will create that remarkable
first impression the checklist also
includes them the tips on how to create
a welcome email series so you know
outlining how to get your brand across
and get your purpose across and you know
really just welcome people to your to
your brand cool so check it out they are
with like I'm such entrepreneurs also
check out that today is your day so just
last day I make sure to put that in the
description thank you guys so much for
joining in the time goes quickly Hudson
seen how fast an hour goes I'm sorry we
didn't get to all the questions but I
appreciate you guys watching in think
you want to go for spending the time
again to come out with us for another
session this month continue to believe
guys and we'll see you soon bye thank
you